this episode is brought to you by
surfshark
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
carlos gom was a lot of things a
powerful ambitious intelligent
businessman bilingual multicultural and
charismatic
many aspired to be like him while others
saw him as nothing more than a
megalomania it seemed like he was always
destined to be remembered and that may
hold true but perhaps not for the
reasons he would have liked
in this episode we'll see how one of the
greatest businessmen rose his way up to
the top and ended up a wanted fugitive
by escaping japanese authorities by
being smuggled in a box
let's take a look
you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
a gifted mathematician and businessman
carlos began making good impressions
straight out of university in 1978 he
joined the company michelin
within three years of working at various
plants across europe he was made a
manager a few years later he was once
again promoted to head of research and
development for the company's industrial
tire division but carlos was far from
done after just one year in that
position at the age of 30 he was
appointed to chief operating officer of
south american operations
[Music]
carlos gohn had a knack for
cross-cultural management this could be
credited to his multicultural upbringing
he was born in brazil moved to lebanon
when he was six and educated in france
he was a self-proclaimed citizen of the
world he used this to his advantage when
he began overseeing operations in
multiple south american countries
while he was with michelin he became
known as a turnaround specialist and
once he had finished turning
unprofitable operations into thriving
ones in south america he made the move
to south carolina with his family to
take up the position of ceo of michelin
north america
one year later he was promoted to ceo
after 18 years with michelin carlos was
seeking a new challenge he had already
built a solid name for himself and a
reputation that landed him a position
with the car manufacturer renault
he was hired as the executive vice
president in charge of purchasing
advanced research engineering and
development powertrain operations and
manufacturing as well as overseeing
renault's south american division
once again carlos proved himself to be
an expert at reorganizing operations and
building profitability
he had an incredible eye for recognizing
how and when a company was in need of
radical restructuring and his changes
paid off for renault
his success with renault put him in a
desirable position when in 1999 the
company bought a 36.8 stake in nissan
which was struggling to maintain
profitability
this was the beginning of the renault
nissan alliance
[Music]
whilst still holding onto his role at
renault carlos gong also took the
position of ceo of nissan a year later
he was president and a year after that
he was named ceo
[Music]
carlos liked a challenge in fact he'd
built a career out of it that's why it
made sense that he was so keen to
oversee nissan which at the time was the
ultimate test
returning nissan to a profitable brand
was widely considered an impossible task
this made it irresistible to carlos
at the time nissan was 20 billion
dollars in debt and only three out of
its 46 car models were profitable
and this is why it seemed ludicrous when
carlos announced the nissan revival plan
under the guidelines of this plan he
would turn nissan around in just three
years
it called for a return to profitability
within one year a 4.5 increase in profit
margin in two years and a 50 reduction
in debt in three years
carlos was confident
so confident he even said that if he was
not able to reach these targets he and
his board would resign
it was a tall order and one that would
require ruthless restructuring carlos
cut 21 000 jobs shut five manufacturing
plants and sold nissan's aerospace unit
which to be honest i didn't even know
they had
he embarked on a dramatic shuffling of
corporate positions and structures
defying japanese business adequate at
every step
by the time carlos was done nissan was
almost unrecognizable but in the
ruthless brutal madness that was
nissan's revival plan there were
well-defined goals and carlos had
achieved each of those goals with nine
months to spare it was a remarkable
achievement
for a foreign businessman to be accepted
by the public while taking over a
japanese company with as much history as
nissan took a lot of convincing but
these initial years of success had done
just that and carlos was shot into the
spotlight becoming a fully fledged
business celebrity
he began regularly appearing in
newspapers magazines and on television
his image was used in comics lunch books
and postage stamps
his previous success quickly became
minor achievements in comparison to what
would be his achievements in the early
2000s
this became most apparent in 2005 when
he assumed the role of ceo at renault
making him the first person in history
to be the ceo of two fortune 500
companies at the same time
carlos was unstoppable and he was
becoming a superstar over the next
decade he became a household name around
the globe but in that time cracks began
to show especially in his working
relationships
by the mid 2010s carlos was no longer in
the business of turning around failing
companies he was in charge of growing
two brands renault was steadily
performing well but nissan had
transformed into a massive powerhouse of
the industry
juggling the two brands across nations
and cultures didn't fit well with his
newfound stardom and jet-setting
lifestyle and his peers began to notice
his absence
the man who once was extremely hands-on
and present was now distant and
preoccupied
but carlos didn't see it this way that's
why in october of 2016 nissan purchased
a 34 stake in mitsubishi motors and
carlos gohn was appointed chairman at
the time mitsubishi was another brand
that needed a facelift the company's
revenue had been falling and they were
deep within an emissions scandal it was
another challenge for carlos to seek his
teeth into
but he had some secrets and they were
about to catch up with him
in november of 2018 as he landed in a
tokyo airport police boarded his private
plane and carlos was arrested over
allegations of false accounting this was
the beginning of a new and unpleasant
chapter in his life
the news was sudden and shocking there
were no rumors or indicators that
something like this was coming which led
many to speculate that this must have
come from within nissan
you see the speculators claimed that
nissan had outgrown the need for such a
man as carlos and had worked with
authorities to remove him from the
company without the need for a payout
the rumor was further fueled when it was
discovered that the reason that carlos
was flying to japan was for an unusually
rushed meeting organised by his
colleagues on short notice
commentators believed that the entire
situation was a trap to catch a man
whose ego had outgrown the company that
he ran
carlos believes that this was a joint
mission by nissan and the japanese
government who feared that france's
renault was attempting to take complete
control over japan's precious nissan
supporters of carlos also note that the
japanese legal system is known to be
corrupt
the system only chases high conviction
rates in the range of over 90 percent
objectively unfair
but regardless of intentions the
evidence of his crimes were actually
real
carlos was stood down from his positions
within the renault nissan mitsubishi
alliance
before we continue a quick word from our
sponsor now you may not be in trouble
with the japanese government like carlos
but you still may want to be protected
and keep your online information private
whether that's from big tech companies
or other parties more privacy is always
good one of the best ways to protect
yourself is by surf shark vpn
with surf shark you can protect yourself
from spying malware and fishing and also
get access to content that's been region
blocked
surfshark is offering you guys an 83
discount if you use the code cold fusion
plus three extra months free to get
started click the link in the
description below thanks now back to the
episode
carlos was obsessed with growth and that
did include his salary he was resentful
of the fact that other ceos of car
manufacturers in countries like the
united states were on significantly
higher wages than he was able to
negotiate and it could be said that he
was doing a much better job than any of
them if he couldn't be officially paid
what he believed he deserved he would
seek out other means of compensation
as it turned out carlos was using nissan
money to pay for a long list of personal
expenses and purchases
he used nissan funds to pay for various
homes across europe and south america a
luxurious private yacht and would use
the nissan private jet for personal
trips like vacationing with his family
he funneled millions of dollars from
nissan accounts into companies related
to his family he also used nissan funds
for elaborate extravagant parties
it was also alleged that carlos with the
help of his co-conspirator and aide greg
kelly set up a complicated structure of
payment plans that allowed 80 million
dollars to go unreported
following the allegations in japan came
similar findings in france when renault
published an internal audit showing 11
million euros worth of questionable
expenses that could be traced back to
carlos
then united states prosecutors also came
after him with allegations that he
failed to report 140 million dollars
that was paid to him by nissan
in all of this he never denied or
admitted to the accusations but instead
settled
he was fined one million dollars while
nissan as a company was fined 15 million
he was also given a 10-year ban from
serving as an officer or director of any
public company
it also turned out that there were
controversies in the way that he ran his
businesses
internal and external investigations
found that through fear and intimidation
carlos was able to run his companies
like a dictator he believed that his
reputation and track record would allow
him to get away with whatever he wanted
in total carlos spent 108 days in
japanese prison before being released on
bail under strict conditions
he was ordered to stay in a heavily
monitored property under 24-hour
surveillance he was without internet
access
if he was to leave it would be under the
supervision of two officers
the japanese authorities had no
intention of letting him out of their
sight
and this is why it came as such a shock
when on the 30th of december of 2019
carlos gone arrived in lebanon
[Music]
since leaving japan carlos has spoken
openly to the media about how he pulled
off his extraordinary feat
he claims that he had no choice but to
escape stating he could quote no longer
be held hostage by a rigged japanese
justice system where guilt is presumed
discrimination is rampant and basic
human rights are denied
here's how he did it
carlos had noticed that officers would
not follow him into a hotel meeting and
this is how he would begin his escape he
claims to have disguised himself in
unusual clothes while wearing a medical
face mask which is common in japan he
used the disguise to first sneak out of
the hotel he then caught a bullet train
to a second hotel where his
co-conspirators had arranged a large
empty audio equipment case for carlos to
sit in
he was then carried out of the hotel
driven out of the city to remote airport
and placed on a private jet
he sat patiently waiting for the plane
to take off and when he re-emerged from
his box he was a free man to avoid
raising suspicions he flew from japan to
turkey then boarded a plane headed to
istanbul he walked out of the airport in
istanbul confident he was free
lebanon doesn't have an extradition
treaty with japan which meant that as
long as carlos stayed there there wasn't
much that the japanese government could
do
but carlos couldn't have pulled this off
on his own and his co-conspirators have
faced severe consequences japanese
authorities in january of 2020 issued
arrest warrants for a former united
states army special forces soldier
michael taylor and his son peter
michael had extensive contracts in
lebanon and had completed similar rescue
missions during his time with the
special forces it was alleged that the
men were paid over 1 million dollars
delivered in a combination of bank
transfers and bitcoin
in may of 2020 united states police
arrested both michael and peter and
eventually handed them over to japanese
authorities
the pair pled guilty and michael is
serving a two-year prison sentence while
his son was given 20 months
in the years since his arrest and
subsequent escape carlos has been
challenged with legal battles from
various nations but has managed to avoid
prison while residing in lebanon
he has been writing a book and posting
on instagram he's hired a hollywood
agent and is posting business classes
for twenty thousand dollars ahead
but it has also been reported that he's
getting revenge
he spent his time meticulously
collecting evidence against nissan and
the japanese government in what he
claims would officially clear his name
to see how this wild twisting story
plays out we'll have to wait and see
[Music]
the story of carlos and his charismatic
rise to success was gradual and
inspiring but his fall from grace was
swift
carlos maintains his innocence and may
never admit his faults and the truth is
yet to be decided but despite the
outcomes of any trials that may
eventuate in the future his legacy may
forever be tarnished and for now as
things stand it remains a cautionary
tale for anyone who believes that
they're too big to fail
so what do you guys think do you think
that carlos is innocent and it was a
plot by the japanese government and
nissan to take him out or do you think
he was a megalomaniac ceo who was really
trying to extract money from the company
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below
though if you do want to discuss in more
detail the best place to do that would
be the cold fusion discord
so that just about wraps it up i'd also
like to say that the podcast has started
up again so if you want to find the
podcast versions of these episodes you
can find it on spotify and some other
platforms links will be below alright so
that's about it for me
my name is tagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion feel free to
subscribe if you want to see more so
i'll see you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys
have a good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's